[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
happy week nine everybody you just
tapped into the br betting squad ride
live in the bleacher report app
presented by draftkings i'm connor
rogers you know that by now but for the
first time yes sir this season he is in
studio with me at bleacher airport new
york city greg ivory the man of the
people coming off the big fight night
how you feeling yes sir feeling good
feeling good uh we won we won some money
yesterday of course lots of money lost a
little bit on wei lee but got it back
with usman so feeling good about that
but connor
i want to feel even better and you know
how i can do that is by giving away
hoodies to the people i'm in the
comments right now i'm in the comments
and i see
i see i see deep geek is in the comments
shout out to d geek he says cooper cup
patterson tds equals the lockheed parlay
shout out to you deep geek michael steve
ritter says the legends are together
that's right
shout out to you mike uh north east l.a
gave us a gift he's cheering us on shout
out to you northeast la from new york
you are walking away with a hoodie
connor let's get this thing on the road
he doesn't come empty-handed he comes to
new york city packs that suitcase
hoodies galore yes sir hi die hoodies
looking good you all know the deal by
now on friday we asked you on social we
ask you in the app we're looking for
those anytime touchdown scores we're
looking for the locks of the week of
who's getting in the end zone this board
you're seeing today is unlike any we've
shown throughout the entire season sure
ezekiel at the top naji hara superstar
rookie alvin kamara we got something a
little special with ak later on in the
show stephon diggs and run cmc returns
to the field those are no surprises
boston scott and dalton schultz at the
bottom those are two guys that you're
probably not used to seeing on the squad
ride board and then travis kelsey was
there as well
he has not gotten in the end zone the
last three weeks travis kelsey
disappointing us a little bit but we're
excited man we got a lot to give away
tell the people what's going on yes sir
connor everybody at home
we are giving away two not one but two
nfl jersey gift cards uh we're also
we're giving away one to the winner of
the lock legend tournament and we're
giving a win we're giving one away to a
lucky commenter like yourself so don't
go nowhere stay tuned stay tapped in
i need gifts i need emojis but most
importantly i need winners only please
type that out right now in the comments
i am giving away hoodies connor and
we've been doing a lot of that we have
now cashed in the squad ride the last
three weeks the last three weeks three
squad i mean and i'll tell you what i
think today we're feeling real real good
let's do it again we have four legendary
picks to show you as always the people
are bringing it with their locks you
know the deal by now last one standing
squad ride leader the most important
thing nfl jersey pretty good prize to
take home as well and we're all gonna
follow that person we're gonna trail the
bet make a lot of money it's time for
round one let's get right into it the
first pitch the first pitch of the day
logan over meyer tell us who's scoring a
touchdown today logan
all right anytime touchdown score who's
it gonna be this week
anytime
touchdown score
dalton schultz making his way into the
squad ride contention here and that is
big that's some of the bigger plus money
we've had on the show here right now
990. i know i know how greg feels about
that plus money and where he can get
that but it's time for the first
decision of the day the first match-up
our second pitch comes from end goldberg
we got atlas here and he's going to pick
our anytime touchdown score of the week
in the blue ball we've got ezekiel
elliott
and
we'll see which one he picks up
ready atlas
he's a little indecisive here
atlas which one
oh he's got the blue ball
and the blue ball here
which atlas just stole again
we got zeke
anytime touchdown scorer of the week
atlas coming in clutch with the ezekiel
elliott pick at -150 not that crazy they
got the broncos on tap today
greg i don't think i'm gonna pick
against atlas on this entire show what i
know how you feel about that plus money
what do we got going on here are the
people feeling connor you know i love
that plus money what i need everybody to
do is get in the comments and let me
know if you are riding with the pool
legend or if you're writing with the
fetch legend are we going with dalton
schultz or ezekiel elliott
week one week two
maybe week three we didn't know who
dalton schultz was we didn't know who he
was dax start feeding them a lot of the
fantasy owners started to pick them up
uh so i like the odds at plus 190 but
there's just a lot of weapons in that
dallas cowboys offense and speaking of
weapons
the other guy ezekiel elliott is a good
weapon so uh i think i want to lean
ezekiel ellie what about you connor i
mean i know what you could do with these
odds right if we can get that minus 150
to even money i feel good about zeke
getting in the end zone this week they
didn't bring michael gallup off ir yet
so they'll be down michael gallup cd
lam's gonna play but he's been nursing
an injury you know what that happens
when those guys are banged up they lean
on their workhorse running back the
million dollar man the guy that's got
the big contract and he comes through in
the clutch all the time for them so
i'm riding with atlas i feel good about
ezekiel elliott yes let's let the handy
dandy ipad decide match up number one
right here handy dandy i am in the
comments i'm in the comments i got
daniel gutman with the zeke gift he gave
us the zeke gift shout out to you daniel
gutman you were walking away with the
hoodie johnny ball game 7-7 zeke is a
lot of juice go for two tds johnny do
not be alarmed brother
we here at the squad ride we can boost
these odds for you so do not be alarmed
by the juice but johnny ball game 77 you
were walking away with the hoodie i got
one more in me connor one more in me i
got renault ray reynald ray zeke fetch
legend for sure and he gave us a gift of
a german shepherd there it is well done
german shepherd
jumping around so shout out to everybody
that i mentioned you are walking away
with hoodie connor
it appears ezekiel elliott is moving on
the people are riding with zeke they're
riding with atlas and that means and
goldberg moves on to round number two
yes sir he's got a long way to go let's
get into it two challengers remaining
let's get into this second round the
next pitch comes from john cooney john
who you riding with here in week number
nine
[Music]
boston's got plus 140 anytime touchdown
let's ride
all right we got the prop wheel legend
you already know we got the fetch legend
prop wheel going with boston scott who
quietly now greg has three touchdowns in
his last two games yeah it's been hot
he's been on but you know how we usually
feel about that yes that usually scares
us away and i know you feel a certain
way about this messy philly backfield
yes yes yes i do feel a way about the
philly backfield but before i get into
that what i need you guys to do is tell
me how you guys feel about boston scott
versus ezekiel elliott who do you think
we should ride with but let's talk about
that backfield in philadelphia
they have three running backs which
means you don't have a main one that's
what i'm saying that's that's what i'm
saying so uh
i don't know i saw jordan howard score a
couple touchdowns uh last week so
i i think i want to lean zeke here
because i know that zeke is the back in
dallas yeah no it's he's the workhorse
guy i mean he's he's got that 100
million dollar contract essentially at
this point you know he's getting the
ball and i love tony pollard when he
mixes in as well but when this comes
down to it yes the odds are very
different for a reason yeah zeke should
find his way into the end zone today i
do love the prop wheel video keep
bringing it
but you know we made our case yeah we've
kind of been guiding the squad each week
since the coup we've been trying to
teach we've been trying to lead you guys
yeah they're trying to lead you all the
way i mean we're three and now and then
are they staying with atlas and zeke or
are they going with the the guy that
comes out of nowhere each year in the
middle of the year in boston scott i'm
in the handy ipad i'm in the handy-dandy
ipad and i see city 31-84 he has the
zeke gift of jumping over a defender
shout out to you city 3184 you are
walking away with the hoodie i got t
gibson 28 says german shepherds know
best elliot anytime touchdown all day
winners only hashtag winners only shout
out to you that is how you get a hoodie
uh here we go i got leros garza larose
garza says
zeke feed that man uh
connor
yeah it's pretty obvious yeah it's
pretty obvious here it's pretty deep
yeah it's moving on zeke got round one
got round two can he pull off the
undefeated stretch here atlas and
goldberg ezekiel elliott i want to see
greg get that to at least even money
that'd be a good time
final
round final round winner takes home
squad ride title winner takes home nfl
jersey hopefully winner gets us week
number four in a row of the squad ride
cash now next up chris johannen15
chris are you going to be able to unseat
atlas
we got alvin kamara we got zeke we got
kelsey who's scoring this weekend
and he looks like
uh-oh
it's kelsey he's scoring this weekend
the roomba legend going with travis
kelsey who
has been ice cold lately he hasn't
scored in his last three games you know
what that usually means yeah he's doing
he's due
kind of ironic we got a dog against a
roomba two things that definitely don't
ever get along all right
fetch legend roomba legend kelsey zeke
these are all reliable things yes
i'm still going with zeke what uh and um
this is a tough call is this gonna sway
you is this gonna sway them
connor you know when these tough
decisions come i usually lean on the
people so guess what i'm gonna do in
this circumstance i'm gonna lean on the
people i'm in the comments you guys let
me know you guys let me know are we
riding with travis kelsey are we riding
with ezekiel elliott
let's find out i got heart attacks hair
attacks winners only travis kelsey gift
shout out to you hair attacks i got
wheezy804
wheezy804s
also says travis kelsey with
a gift connor so all right hold on hold
on hold on city don't go i see i see
zeke red sox and five zeke lock kaboom
shout out to you uh i also see
blake steamin
zeke easy money winners only
connor it's 2-2 it's 2-2 the next one i
i'm winner takes off winner takes all
here we go winner takes off scrolling
bam ashley guerrero
ashley guerrero zeke is gonna eat
feed that man zeke connor it's apparent
i we didn't said it
zeke
elliott ezekiel elliott is winning the
squad ride can we please pull up the
graphics i could show you what can you
do with this at home what we can do on
the squad ride
do not be alarmed that it's minus 150
because the magic is gonna happen just
like this poof there it is
now it is plus 100 shout out to our
people over at draftkings for doing that
for us connor uh
let's go man this is a beautiful thing
to see plus money the people trailed us
they trailed atlas i'm ready for week
number four in a row of a win we are not
done no you're not the man is here he's
still got another jersey he's still got
plenty of hoodies and we got locks and
now it's time for the community
comment contest yes and listen we're
halfway through the season we got to ask
you the layup question of all lab
questions of future bets
who's going to win this mvp right it's
time to check in halfway through you got
a good idea what quarterback's on fire i
think it's pretty even at the top of
course but we asked you in the br ben
and community stream in the app
who it's gonna be look at this group
right here right we got josh allen at
the top kind of a clear favorite that's
a big disparity between odds and he's
had a great year 17 touchdowns through
the air i think he's got three on the
ground already the bills are looking
like the best team in the afc i know you
were all on the bill's mafia train
before this season started stafford
rejuvenated with sean mcvay in the rams
he's been great tom brady has pretty
much been tom brady kyler murray banged
up right now but he's been a star
especially in the fantasy world aaron
rodgers we know there's all kinds of
problems there i don't think a lot of
people are going to be throwing mvp
money on him as he's expecting this time
lamar jackson pretty low down the list
for how special he is all it takes is
one game all it takes is one game
no dak prescott on this list surprising
surprising and he's missed one game but
he's been great
i want to know what the people are
saying i want to know what comments you
dove into and want to show connor
let me get into the comments let me get
into the comments
because i just feel like giving out a
hoodie i mean i'm in new york feeling
generous it's cold here it's cold so i
just want to give out eddie i see i see
big mike 13 says allen deserves mvp and
i must keep it right there because i
like josh allen to win mvp but what i
need you guys to do is tell me which
comment i'm gonna read which comment you
guys like better uh
let's get into it man let's let's
jump right into it starting off with
sauce 90. starting off with sauce 90.
sauce 90 says i got the goat
tom brady winning that
i guess mvp uh then he goes emoji emoji
championship emoji championship emoji
those are two go-to emojis if you guys
don't know but connor what do you what
do you think about this take
i mean he's done it three times already
right he's won the mvp three times
already he is obviously the household
name of the nfl the one thing that
scares me greg besides the fact that
he's got good healthy competition on
that board i believe in brady fatigue
for the voting i really do i have a
belief that there's some brady fatigue
that if he's not leaps and bounds better
than all of those guys they'll give it
to a younger guy they'll give it to
someone else so not a crazy comment it's
never crazy to bet on tom brady but i'm
curious what the second comment has to
say about this race let's hop into it
connor let's hop into a dylan raymond
dylan raybun says in what world has josh
allen played better than dak
and stafford what a joke
you know what the dak hate or the lack
of dak love i should say i'm with you on
that i think dak he's missed the game so
the reason being is this is a numbers
game in the mvp race he's going to be
behind in the passing yards he's going
to be behind in the touchdowns for now
but i think he's been the best
quarterback in the nfl when he's been on
the field but quite frankly the mvp
isn't necessarily the best quarterback
in the nfl all the time the mvp can
basically be a numbers game a team
that's winning you look at josh allen
and the bills they're going to run
through that division there's no doubt
about that so
i like the comment i totally get it i'm
with you on the dak club the mvp race
can be complicated yes sir mvp race can
be complicated i told you guys about
josh allen early on
he's he's the favorite now uh you can
join the train he gets his rushing okay
he gets those right he has three this
year yeah he does get those rushing
touchdowns
connor i'm in the comments i am in the
comments seeing who are we choosing uh
for your partner here our
contest here uh
i see maxwell rexella in the comments
maxwell rexella's in the comments shout
out to you uh big mike 13 says winners
only please uh blake steeman blake
steeman says cooper cup
uh winners only uh
shout out to austin 981 he got he has
kyler murray
everybody i mention your walk away with
hoodie connor
i'm gonna choose i'm just gonna choose
one i like sauce 90. i like sauce 90s
comment he's going to win the contest
everybody that i just mentioned you guys
are walking away with me uh
connor sauce 90 is also walking away
with a shout out to you for your take
bro i like it sauce all right before we
close out the show we can't let you come
to new york and not do our bowl to spend
yes sir and we got to get hot again
right we had we started out a little
cold we got really hot and now it's been
tough this time of year and that's why
greg and i we're kind of teaming up on
this one before we give that away tell
the people what we need for boldest pets
what i need you guys to do what i need
you guys to do is get in the comments
get in the comments and let me know
actually just just just just give us
goodbyes yeah i need a lot of sunsets in
the comments you guys go on your phone
go to the emoji section click a sunset
and fill those comments up with sunsets
because we need good vibes we're not
going against each other we're on the
same team here i'm here we're on the
same team here tell the people what we
are riding with sunsets please guys
let's get it going the name you gotta
know here is alvin kamara you need to be
watching that saints game i think alvin
kamara gets in the end zone not once but
twice today sean payton always brings a
little extra juice against those atlanta
falcons the falcons have given up at
least eight touchdowns to running backs
this year they have been
a weakness against running backs we know
ak can do it through the air we know we
can do it on the ground we know that
their quarterback playing today cannot
throw the ball down the face yes so what
does that mean rely on alvin kamara and
i think you got a little bit of the same
vibes right now tell the people where
you're going connor we have sunsets in
the comments shout out to everybody let
me give away a hoodie i got a t
ty rowley15 thank you for the sunsets
you are walking away with a hoodie
let me jump in here i want to go alvin
kamara first touchdown score my guy
connor mentioned
they're where they have their backup
quarterback in half the backup
quarterback
quarterback in facing the atlanta
falcons defense they're at that'll scare
you yeah yeah they don't neither does
take some help no exactly
trevor simeon i think starts and trevor
simmons
yes but we know we know it both a lot of
checkdowns a lot of checkdowns to ac uh
aka so uh
i'm rocking with it i'm rocking with it
man i i think we're going to get a check
down to alvin kamara and he's going to
score first touchdown and then he's
going to score again
maybe in the second quarter third
quarter that'd be pretty nice plus 380
on the double touchdowns plus 450 on the
first touchdown he is the saints offense
right now even when jameis was healthy
he's the saints office and simeon was
able to
keep the chains moving last week which
is a good sign but it revolves all
around alvin kamara so if you want to
trail today you're trailing the alvin
kamara props come on yeah that's the way
to do it on the train join the train
that is the way to do it did we give
away that last jersey
let's give it out now
a lot of people are in the comments
connor you see that a lot of sunsets are
in the comments a lot of sunsets there
it is you guys can see my screen the lot
of keep the sunsets flowing please
because we need good vibes and good
vibes only let me give away this jersey
counter oh i like this sunset right here
that's the best one young gravy 56 young
gravy 56 you see the sun setting there
connor it's such a good
beautiful sight shout out to you young
gravy56 you are walking away with a
jersey
that's that's love man that's that's i'm
gonna give away one more hoodie not
marvin bagels you're in the perfect spot
you're right under the beautiful sunset
so you're walking away with hoodie
connor is it time to get up out of here
it's been fun man it's been fun my guy's
got to get home yeah he's been on the
road way too long he hasn't gotten to
sleep i got to get home as well and
watch these props hit good luck with all
your wagers everyone congrats all our
hoodie and jersey winners you know the
deal by now br betting is gonna dm you
within the next 24 hours so have no fear
you're getting that gear thank you to
everyone who commented we always
appreciate that comment stream flowing
on the handy dandy ipad lock legends
logan overmeyer and goldberg john cooney
chris johannan15 all brought it today
shout out to atlas the fetch legend
making some money for us today atlas oh
my god connor wait i'm sorry brother i
didn't mean i i i i cut it you off in
person that
usually it's usually it feels good
honestly it's usually uh when i'm at
home but connor hold on i gotta get back
into the comments uh because i'm in new
york and i'm giving away hoodies because
why not i got packer nation 420 it's
giving the sunset sending this good vibe
shout out to excitation for the sun
stayed for the sunset enderman enderman
is back shout out to you enderman for
the sunset vibes you were walking away
with the hoodie uh here we go t gibson
28 let's go let's go you're walking away
with hoodie
connor that's it that's it that's it all
good things must come doing it it's been
a lot of fun today enjoy your football
sunday follow the squad if you don't get
it by now the last three weeks yes the
touchdown scoring is happening and this
week you already know the deal by now
we're watching ck elliott we're watching
alvin kamara alongside greg ivory here
in bleacher airport new york city that
sounds good that feels good my name is
connor rogers see you next week same
time same place peace
[Music]
foreign